[Music]
hello
it's time again for dear drew i love
getting all of your letters
but before i get to our first one let's
celebrate our zip code of the day
it's 206.03
maryland that's right give it up for
waldorf
waldorf was originally called beantown
named after a local family
and it's home of the southern maryland
blue crabs baseball team waldorf
maryland we would love to hear from you
send us some mail and now to our letter
dear miss barrymore thanks makes me feel
like a school
teacher i'm writing today to ask you if
you would be kind enough to help me
with a project i began many years ago to
collect an entire deck of autographed
playing cards
my goal has been to seek out people from
a wide variety of fields who have had a
significant and positive impact in their
field and on popular culture
i would be truly honored to be able to
include you in my project of amazing
people like
julia childs hank aaron
bob hope and carol burnett
chris waldorf marilyn
first of all thank you for including me
and such an esteemed group of people
i would be honored to join your card
project is there yes there is a card
here it is oh the five of clubs
sounds good to me okay let me just i'm
gonna do it with a sharpie
it feels more permanent more stable
okay chris all my
love drew
barrymore i was really nervous to mess
that up
i'm not gonna lie by the way chris
i always tell my kids something about a
deck of playing cards
never get rid of your jokers
it's a good good tip
all right i think it's all good to go i
will put it in the
envelope thank you so much for
including me in your project i'm honored
to be a part of it
and i'm gonna put it in our mailbox all
right chris
thank you so much truly yours drew
you